è un grande piacere essere qui e
raccontarvi di un progetto di energia
rinnovabile
un'avventura fatta di speranza e paura
anche di coraggio
che di strada ne ha fatta ma ce n'è
ancora ce n'è ancora da lottare Dunque
il tema di questa sera è la paura
che tratterò appunto col tema
dell'energia rinnovabili in questo
settore la paura si può trovare su
diversi livelli parlo un po' per me per
i miei colleghi la paura di chi porta
avanti il progetto che Nel gergo tecnico
si dice lo sviluppatore che ha paura di
non vedere il progetto realizzato di
fallire il suo investimento perdendo un
sacco di soldi
ma anche la paura dei cittadini e il
cosiddetto effetto nimby dall'inglese
Nothing i Baker cioè di volere sì le
rinnovabili ma lontano dal proprio
cortile
e infine Forse la paura più grande che
coinvolge la società globale cioè quella
del surriscaldamento dovuto al
cambiamento climatico
partiamo proprio dall'ultimo punto il
più importante e A proposito facciamo
una sorta di gioco ognuno di noi si
chieda veramente in se stesso in se
stessa se ha paura del cambiamento
climatico
non è una paura diretta che si può
vedere come quella che hanno parlato
Gli ospiti prima di me è una paura che
per certi aspetti è invisibile
e probabilmente secondo me ognuno di noi
la sottostima Perché l'essere umano
tende sempre a sottostimare i pericoli
nel lungo termine però dobbiamo dare a
questo problema il giusto peso e per
farlo osserviamo il numero che vedete in
sovraimpressione
è un numero che ci dovrebbe preoccupare
sono circa i chilogrammi di anidride
carbonica equivalente che ogni anno la
specie umana Quindi anch'io anche voi e
mette e mette nell'atmosfera troppi
fatti dall'invenzione della macchina a
vapore quindi il conseguente avvio della
prima rivoluzione industriale in
Inghilterra le missioni della nostra
specie sono cresciute a dismisura
fino giungere al livello insostenibile
che causa il surriscaldamento globale e
le catastrofi dovute al cambiamento
climatico
a detta di molti scienziati l'unica via
di scampo è azzerare queste missioni con
anche azioni di compensazione
e raggiungere quello che loro
definiscono il Net Zero
usando una metafora immaginiamo una
vasca
piena d'acqua che tra poco
inesorabilmente deborderà
l'unica cosa che puoi fare per
interrompere diciamo questo corso è non
diminuire il flusso d'acqua ma
completamente spegnere i rubinetti e
anzi togliere un po' di quell'acqua per
evitare che si possa creare un rischio e
altrimenti le conseguenze ambientali
potrebbero essere catastrofiche
però
Ci vuole un po' di coraggio no azzerare
i consumi Anzi le missioni di questo
pianeta diciamo entro il 2050 è
possibile in teoria
In pratica è un po' più complesso e Fra
le tante cose che servono sicuramente
c'è anche tanta innovazione A proposito
di innovazione Io sono il direttore
operativo di Agnes una società nata nel
2019 a Ravenna con poche persone in un
piccolo ufficio di Fornace Zarattini
però con un grande obiettivo molto
ambizioso cioè sviluppare impianti
energetici sostenibili ed altamente
innovativi di grandi dimensioni in mare
che possono produrre elettricità pulita
per milioni di persone sperando di
cambiare la loro vita per sempre
ovviamente le nostre iniziative non
saranno La Panacea del cambiamento
climatico ma sicuramente vanno nella
giusta direzione per abbattere quei 50
milioni di chili e raggiungere il
cosiddetto ne0
Siccome siamo di Ravenna e molti di noi
sono ravennati vi voglio parlare nello
specifico di un progetto che sorgerà
circa 20 chilometri dalle nostre coste e
una volta realizzato potrà coprire il
fabbisogno energetico di circa 500.000
famiglie a livello domestico
ciò che stiamo tentando di fare è un po'
un unico nel panorama energetico perché
vorremmo realizzare amare due impianti
eolici e un impianto fotovoltaico
galleggiante Che frutta sulle onde e poi
in aree portuale realizzare sia sistemi
per lo stoccaggio dell'Elettricità con
batterie ma anche sistemi per la
produzione di idrogeno verde che è un
gas che è amico dell'ambiente poiché
privo di emissioni nocive quindi le
missioni in fase di esercizio saranno
pressoché nulle e la fase di esercizio
durerà 25 30 anni producendo elettroni
puliti per le nostre case per le nostre
Industrie
quindi il progetto è sì tanto ambizioso
quanto eccitante ma a questo punto vi
chiederete dove sta la paura
Beh innanzitutto nel 2019 quando siamo
partiti detto francamente non saremo mai
dovuti partire
perché c'erano veramente troppe ragioni
per dirottarci su altro e farci mollare
in partenza
sforzi economici incertezze normative
ostacoli tecnici dubbi strategici chi
più ne ha più ne metta
forse siamo stati un po' come come il
calabrone che non ha la struttura alare
per volare ma il calabrone non lo sa e
vola lo stesso ma così come questa frase
dell'entomologo francese Magnani è stata
smentita dalla scienza così anche noi
siamo partiti lo stesso Forse con una
sana dose di incoscienza Ma perché
inizialmente le premesse erano così
avverse
Prima di tutto non eravamo in un luogo
ideale per le rinnovabili cioè l'Italia
a volte sui giornali si leggono spesso
titoli sezionalistici che
ci fanno credere che noi a livello di
paese siamo molto virtuosi dal punto di
vista della sostenibilità ambientale ed
energetica
interpretiamo questi titoli che forse
con un eccesso ottimismo un eccesso di
ottimismo È pur vero che rispetto
all'elettricità che produciamo circa il
40% di questa è prodotta in modo
sostenibile quindi verde ma
l'elettricità è solo una fetta
dell'energia totale in tutte le sue
altre forme che noi necessitiamo
necessitiamo per mandare avanti questo
paese il resto delle fonti di energia
prevalentemente è occupato dal gas poi
dal petrolio e dal Carbone che quindi
sono combustibili fossili che hanno
emissioni nocive per l'ambiente Quindi
alla fine della fiera facendo i calcoli
Giusti ci ritroviamo che ai livelli
prepandemici del 2019
solo il 6,5% dell'energia che consumiamo
è stata prodotta da solare ed eolico
troppo poco
un altro motivo per cui non saremmo
dovuti partire era Che nel 2019 non
esistevano progetti di olii of Shore
quindi oligo Marino
in Italia né tantomeno abbia energetici
innovativi come quelli che stiamo
proponendo basti pensare che l'impianto
fotovoltaico più grande d'Italia non
arrivava a 100 Megawatt mentre avevamo i
nostri colleghi spagnoli che
installavano gli impianti solari più
grandi del continente
quindi in questo contesto Abbiamo
cominciato a bussare alla porta
d'istruzioni in ambito regionale
Nazionale ma anche di aziende per
trovare come dire
supporto dei partner e molti ci
prendevano per matti ci dicevano che in
Italia queste cose non si sono mai fatte
non si faranno
e ovviamente le porte sbattute dopo che
l'abbiamo aperte sono state tante
e hanno fatto piuttosto male però ciò
non è bastato fermarci forti della forza
di un sogno e dell'energia di un idea
che può veramente cambiare le cose
un altro motivo per cui non saremo mai
dovuti partire e che non esisteva una
legge per approvare questi impianti come
se tu vuoi fare qualcosa ma qualcuno ti
dice no non puoi farla perché non c'è
una regola Ci rimani un po' male a dire
il vero una regola c'era e spiegava Come
fare gli impianti entro le 12 miglia
nautiche Peccato che in tutta Europa
ormai si facevano lontano dalla costa
per diminuire gli impatti visivi
paesaggistici sul turismo sulla pesca
perché in Italia si è fatto una legge
solo per realizzare impianti entro le 12
miglia quindi vicino alla costa
non vi aspettate una risposta perché non
ce l'ho e non ci trovo il senso credo
sia un altro paradosso italiano
che poi in effetti una legge ancora non
esiste Ma questo è un altro discorso
sono cavoli nostri infine un'altra
ragione per cui questo progetto non
l'avremmo dovuto fare è Che nel 2019
eravamo semplicemente una startup fatta
di poche persone
vi confesso che all'inizio più di una
volta mi sono scoraggiato a pensare alla
marea di legge di ostacoli normativi e
tecnici di soldi che servivano per
questo progetto
avevo paura che la miriade di variabili
impazzite ci sovrastasse facendoci fare
solo la figura dei sognatori
questa paura a dir la verità ancora è
presente
Perché diciamo che il ritmo di questo
lavoro è come scandito da un pendolo che
oscilla tra un problema e una nuova
soluzione continuamente
però nel tempo siamo cresciuti
assumendo ragazze e ragazzi che che con
coraggio persone di coraggio che hanno
portato valore ai nostri sforzi di
progettazione non ci siamo sentiti più
soli e l'Unione ha fatto la forza
come potete immaginare Abbiamo
combattuto diverse battaglie abbiamo
dovuto sbattere i pugni sul tavolo con
tre aziende istituzioni molto più grandi
di noi
abbiamo avuto la sensazione di non
essere Magari a volte presi sul serio a
volte abbiamo dovuto proteggere la
sostenibilità economica ambientale di
questo progetto a volte abbiamo
semplicemente dovuto combattere contro
dei pesci più grossi che ci volevano
mangiare
però spostando un attimo la prospettiva
la paura in questo settore come detto
all'inizio non è solo dei cittadini non
è solo delle aziende anche dei cittadini
Scusate
per esempio la paura degli albergatori e
l'impatto sul turismo causato dalle
turbine eoliche
la paura dei contadini per la
sottrazione di terreni in cui realizzare
impianti fotovoltaici e in generale la
paura che molti di noi possono avere per
la deturpazione del paesaggio i paesaggi
in cui sono cresciuti che e che amano
sono paure reali sensate a cui però
devono essere associati due aspetti
molto importanti Il primo è che non
bisogna mai stancarsi di creare un
dibattito serio e tecnico fra
istituzioni private e cittadini senza
sfociare l'ideologie e conflitti di
interesse e secondo la realizzazione di
studi ambientali basati su dati e
impatti certi previsti a cui possono
essere associate dell'efficacia misure
di mitigazione In questo modo si può e
si deve togliere il freno alle
rinnovabili riportato vi porto un dato
pensate che tra il 2017 e il 2022 sono
stati presentati circa 20 gigawatt di
progetti di oligo che è un quantitativo
di energia incredibile e solo il 3,2% di
questi sono stati approvati
il resto dei progetti è probabilmente
sta fluttuando nel nulla quindi sembra a
volte che come dico coi miei colleghi a
livello politico istituzionale chi deve
approvare questi progetti sia in un film
di interstellar no che a causa dello
spazio tempo
un'oretta nel suo ufficio corrisponde a
6/7 anni nella nostra realtà
Però non si può dire sempre Piove
governo ladro Cioè dobbiamo anche
capire che se dobbiamo renderci più
sostenibili ed indipendenti anche adesso
è una parola che va molto di moda
Indipendenza energetica dipendente a
livello energetico anche la cittadinanza
deve fare la sua parte perché questi
ritmi sicuramente non ci consentono di
raggiungere il Net zero o comunque di
scongiurare catastrofi non sono io a
dirlo è che non sono l'ultimo arrivato
sono gli scienziati
Nel caso specifico di Ravenna però
voglio fare un discorso a parte perché i
nostri concittadini a partire dal
sindaco dalle associazioni di categoria
ci sono distinte rispetto a molte
province italiane in cui le energie
rinnovabili vengono scacciati via
hanno sempre mostrato interesse una
curiosità vogliono Sì capirci di più
come giusto che sia ma sono tutt'altro
che ostativi Anzi direi propositivi
e veramente voglio anche quello
l'occasione per dire che il loro
coraggio e la loro curiosità ci hanno
dato tanto supporto fino ad oggi e se
siamo qui vicini all'obiettivo lo
dobbiamo anche a loro
Per concludere spero di avere di avere
lanciato un messaggio chiaro
che il presagio del cambiamento
climatico spaventa più che mai la
società globale e lo fa adesso quando da
presagio Ormai è diventato un dato reale
tangibile che si vede si può constatare
perché tante popolazioni in giro per il
mondo ma anche noi quest'estate con la
società l'abbiamo percepito cioè i
cambiamenti sono reali
e non sono solo dovuti a come dire Trend
climatici è un cambiamento antropogemico
così come si dice Nel gergo scientifico
ma è proprio per questo motivo che oggi
aziende cittadini istituzioni si devono
riunire Ognuno di loro deve sconfiggere
le proprie paure e cambiare il corso
della storia lo possiamo fare quindi
diciamo il vento soffia il sole splende
e avanti tutti a forza e coraggio Grazie
[Applauso]